les moldaves commémore la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale les 77 ans après
la défaite des nazis le conflit
ukrainien est aujourd'hui dans tous les
esprits selon les renseignements
américains l'armée de vladimir poutine
pourrait tenter de conquérir toute la
zone qui relie la moldavie aux
territoires pro-russes de donetsk est
lougansk
estimant que le président poutine se
prépare à un conflit prolongé en ukraine
où il a encore l'intention d'atteindre
des objectifs au delà du donbass nous
pensons que ces objectifs stratégiques
n'ont pas changé nos informations
montrent que les militaires russes
veulent aussi étendre le pont terrestre
à la transnistrie la transnistrie situé
le long de la frontière avec l'ukraine
est un territoire autonome
auto-proclamée contrôlés par des
séparatistes pro russes mais la moldavie
et les états unis ne reconnaissent pas
cette indépendance
ces derniers jours plusieurs explosions
en transnistrie ont accru les tensions
dans cette zone le gouvernement a
attribué ces tirs à des groupes pro
russe qui chercheraient à entraîner le
pays dans la guerre du rwanda
nous comprenons que certaines forces
agissent dans l'ombre et pourrait
utiliser cette vulnérabilité qu'on mette
en oeuvre des provocations la menace qui
nous préoccupe le plus c'est surtout le
risque d'une déstabilisation de l'ordre
à l'intérieur du pays
pour le moment les autorités moldaves ne
croit pas au scénario d'une invasion
russe mais elle se prépare à une
possible escalade la guerre en ukraine a
déjà des conséquences concrètes sur
l'économie du pays et la hausse des prix
la moldavie peuplé de seulement 2
millions et demi d'habitants a déjà
accueilli plus de 450 milles ukrainien
sur son sol